on les retrouve dans les véhicules
autonomes les assistants vocaux dans le
domaine de la santé ou encore en
agriculture
l'intelligence artificielle et de plus
en plus présente dans nos vies mais
l'élève est en train de dépasser le
maître la machine pourrait bientôt avoir
le déçu on parle d'éléments qui sont
cent mille fois plus puissants qu'un
cerveau humain cette capacité de calcul
là a accès à toute fin pratique à tout
ce que les humains ont produit comme
connaissance depuis l'histoire
l'humanité l'Internet toutes les textes
qu'on a écrit tous les livres tous les
poèmes tous les entrevues tout est là
longtemps réservé aux initiés
l'intelligence artificielle et
maintenant accessible aux communs des
mortels en quelques clics l'arrivée de
robots conversationnels comme chat GPT
qui peut répondre à nos questions et
exécuter des tâches comme rédiger une
offre d'emploi a provoqué une prise de
conscience par exemple ou même bird
maintenant dans les outils de Google
centaines de millions d'usagés partout
dans le monde avec une technologie qu'on
comprend pas l'IA avec ce qui s'en vient
avec ses grands modèles génératifs mais
ça augmente l'importance peut-être
l'urgence d'agir les modèles génératifs
sont capables de produire des textes ou
des images qui semblent avoir été créés
par lui-même bref du contenu qui nous
apparaît comme étant vrai même s'il ne
l'est pas réellement dans les derniers
mois par exemple on a vu de fausses
photos du pape François vêtus de manteau
blanc très stylé et on a également vu de
fausses images de l'arrestation de
Donald Trump
et ça peut aller encore plus loin avec
l'hyper trucage comme la fausse entrevue
de Justin Trudeau menée par georgen
l'animateur de balado américain très
écouté c'est vraiment ça le point pivot
dans lequel on a basculé depuis le mois
de janvier on serait pas capable à l’œil
nu ou à leur est nu de faire la
distinction entre ballons sauf
franchement si on enregistrement c'est
fabriqué ou
change pas ma sucre c'est le vrai
Premier ministre juste un Trudeau donc
on vient de créer une énorme capacité à
la désinformation qui est pas encadrée
autre risque perdre le contrôle de la
machine puisque les systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle après une
par eux-mêmes mais qu'ils sont de plus
en plus puissants certains pourraient
développer de nouvelles capacités à
l'insu de leur créateurs et aller trop
loin le système intelligent optimiserait
pour un objectif qu'on lui a donné sans
tenir compte de tout le reste ils savent
pas qu'à l'extérieur de ce monde-là
nous autres il y a une planète et un
contexte beaucoup plus large
c'est ce qu'on appelle le problème
d'alignement un système qui finirait par
emprunter une trajectoire différente que
souhaitée explique l'entreprise au
pénéal qui est derrière tchat GPT dans
cette vidéo un problème dit-elle qu'il
faut absolument régler pour le bien de
l'humanité il faut avoir
pour donner un exemple un peu
caricatural on pourrait imaginer un
système dont la mission est d'implanter
des usines et qui voudraient en tapisser
la terre entière sans laisser de place
aux humains ça fait ça beaucoup beaucoup
de torts ça peut être utilisé comme une
arme ça il y a aucun doute c'est cette
capacité là à être hyper focalisé hyper
performant sans tenir compte de tout ce
qui est important pour nous nos valeurs
les droits humains la façon qu'on
fonctionne en société qui fait peur à
des gens comme Jacky
l'intelligence artificielle Jeffrey
Hinton a démissionné de son poste chez
Google pour alerter le public quant au
danger de la technologie qui va lui-même
contribué à développer une menace
d'utile encore plus importante que les
changements climatiques il évoque
notamment la création de robots soldats
mais de façon générale Jeffrey Hinton
craint l'emprise que des systèmes
autonomes pourraient exercer sur les
humains si jamais il réalise le plus
grand contrôle serait bénéfique pour
atteindre leurs objectifs
il est possible que l'humanité soit une
phase passagère dans l'histoire de
l'intelligence dit-il dans cette
entrevue à donne à changer je pense
qu'on s'attendait pas avoir des systèmes
aussi compétents le choix D'Angio fait
partie des milliers d'experts qui ont
signé une lettre ouverte en mars dernier
pour réclamer un moratoire de 6 mois sur
le développement de l'intelligence
artificielle le temps de réglementer le
secteur qui a évolué plus rapidement
qu'on l'imaginait il y a des risques il
y a des dangers c'est vraiment important
de pas laisser seul au taux régulation
si les firmes d'intelligence
artificielle ne semble pas avoir pris de
pause la professeur Catherine Régis se
réjouit néanmoins de l'impact de la
lettre ouverte dont elle est aussi
signataire ça a vraiment créer un
électrochoc assez puissant non seulement
à l'échelle locale mais vraiment
internationale il y a eu il y a un débat
qu'on a jamais eu le Canada a déjà
déposé le projet de loi C27 qui vise
encadrer l'intelligence artificielle le
gouvernement pour renommer un
commissaire qui recevra des plaintes et
qui aura le pouvoir de mettre fin aux
initiatives qui en freinent la loi parmi
les objectifs protégés les données
personnelles des Canadiens et éviter que
des systèmes génèrent des résultats
biaisés qui pourraient causer des
préjudices je trouve que c'est un pas
dans la bonne direction ça ça amène
aussi l'idée qu'on va voir la
réglementation en secteur de l'IA et
tout ce qui est d'impact sur les droits
des personnes par exemple potentielles
plus on va demander des exigences envers
les gens qui développent pour et qui
mettent en marché finalement pour
s'assurer que ça soit adéquat l'Union
européenne travaille également sur une
réglementation reste à voir ce que
feront les Américains la question est
cruciale puisque les États-Unis sont la
première force mondiale dans le secteur
pour l'instant l'administration Biden
dévoiler un énoncé de principe
il faut armée qui n'aime pas
un espèce de blueprint là sur alia c'est
c'est pas encore contraignant là il
reste encore beaucoup de chemin à faire
idéalement un encadrement mondial serait
mis en place pour que la planète soit au
diapason à défaut de s'arrêter sur le
développement faut vraiment accélérer
les conversations sur la gouvernance sur
la réglementation il faut qu'elle
collectivement on s'informe on sait dire
l'intelligence artificielle a le pouvoir
de changer nos vies pour le mieux mais
il faut d'abord s'organiser pour éviter
le pire